one thing I also love about you because
I have a lot of friends that have
suffered from postpartum depression and
people don't understand it if you've
never experienced it right like even
them describing to me like I I never
really quite you can't get what
someone's feeling and I love how not
only you were open about it but then
people came against you about it and you
ended up writing the op-ed about I I
think that that is so important and I
know it's not easy to do like you said
it's not easy to do when you're an
actress or anybody in the public eye
people like just shut up and sing or
shut up and act like you know they don't
want you to have an opinion about
anything and and even though you're a
human in a society and living with
everybody else but it it was so it's so
important because not a lot of people
have a voice for that and you have a
giant Spotlight on you so for you to not
only stand up for yourself but stand up
for all those other women it was
incredible and it's like one of my
favorite things you've ever done and and
it just takes it takes a lot of guts to
do something like that and bravery is it
was it easy for you to do you do well in
situations like that you know what I'm
saying I I think writing a book is a
very introverted sort of uh you know
action you sort of you really do have to
sit with your your thoughts and really
kind of be willing to go there so that
was a very comfortable
um Endeavor for me
um telling the story it didn't feel I
don't know if it was courageous but it
was necessary and I think that as a
mother of a daughter at the time now two
daughters I I owe it to them to be to
tell the truth about something that is
so frightening so many people suffer
untreated it can be a it can be
devastating and really just to say I
don't want to feel alone I can't be the
only one feeling this yeah please and it
was a plea as well for people to you
know for to to learn that I wasn't alone
and that and the power and being able to
ask for help and you know there's no
shame in it and and I think that's not
the way you know I grew up you just
stiff upper lip and you just you know
show must go on and that's what you do
and and this undid me and and when I
started doing research on it I thought
someone's got to tell this story because
people or families are suffering yeah
you know the the people around who love
the person going through it they don't
know what to do you know they don't know
how to fix it because it doesn't and
it's custom made it is custom made each
person and it's brilliant because it
answers all the negative questions and
they all it is an imbalance it's
biochemical
and you know you feel that that word
crazy keeps being floated around you and
you just keep thinking what's wrong with
me people have been having babies since
the dawn of time and they gaze down at
their infant and their hair Cascades and
the baby lifts up and it's all as well
and everything's perfect and and it's
just it's a lot harder and I just wanted
to be able to be honest about it because
I knew nobody was talking about this and
I thought I refuse to find shame in this
I need to get through this I love that
you say it's like a plea and like
reaching out as well that's that's what
living is about connecting I think in
relationships and making it always you
know and again it's tough but it's it's
you can get through these things and and
ask for help you know absolutely
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]